the 33rd annual awards of the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences
this is the Civic Auditorium in Santa
Monica California where we will join the
members and guests of the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences for the
most important single event of the
international entertainment year their
annual awards presentation
the artists and craftsmen who make
motion pictures possible await the
awards program which opens with the
overture a medley of songs written for
motion pictures by Arthur freed and a co
herb Brown play by the Academy Awards
Orchestra Andre Previn conducting
and then
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences mr. Valentine Davies
fellow members of the Academy honored
guests welcome to our 33rd annual awards
tonight we are in a new theater and our
presentations are being telecast over
new network the Academy welcomes our
association with American Broadcasting
Company and looks forward to friendly
and fruitful cooperation in the years
ahead but essentially the Academy's
purpose is the same as it always has
been
namely to honor the outstanding film
achievements for the year past for over
30 years now members of this Academy are
voted by secret ballot to select the
winners their vote has been based on
their professional appraisal of what is
the best achievement in each of the
various categories the awards which will
be presented here tonight represent the
considered opinion of 2,300 outstanding
craftsmen in this industry whose
knowledge and judgment democratically
expressed will honor our winners here
are the Oscars but which will be handed
out tonight at the moment none of these
gold statuettes is engrave because we do
not yet know who the winners are only
one man in the world has this
information mr. bill Miller of Price
Waterhouse & Company mr. Miller
ladies it your certificate that price
Waterhouse's tabulated the balance is
altering they sealed envelope thank you
very much mr. Miller as usual as usual
the present is left holding the bank and
now to begin the presentation of the
awards I am delighted to introduce our
master of ceremonies a distinguished
American to whom all of us owe many
thanks for many memories mr. Bob Hope
thank you Valentine thank you ladies and
gentlemen good evening and welcome to
jackpot crane this is the historic
occasion in which the members of the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences decide which actor and actress
has the best press agent
now it's a whole new thing I didn't
realize there was any campaigning at all
going on till I saw my maid wearing a
chill wheels button but it is exciting
we have more candidates here than the
Congo and I use the comparison advisedly
for the past month Hollywood has made
Katanga province look like Pasadena
I wouldn't say feeling has been running
high but if the Alamo doesn't win they
may do it over again live right here
tonight we're coming to you from Santa
Monica by the sea and what a touching
sight this is in front of me gathered in
mass or the finest actors and actresses
in the picture industry and behind me
somewhere out there all alone is Lloyd
Bridges
who will be trolling for losers now
we're telecasting for the magnificent
new Santa Monica Civic Auditorium in the
summer this whole thing is a live bait
barge
this is quite a departure holding the
Academy Awards in Santa Monica
that makes two towns I've lost it we
have to move the awards presentation
from Hollywood
last year the losers were throwing
themselves on the freeway but they're
tempting fate to hold this Roman holiday
on the shores of the ocean any moment
the sea will park and Otto Preminger
will appear with a whip and drive us all
back to the Pantages
it's it's been a great year for the
industry movies are your best
entertainment ask anybody who watches
television and there's a new feeling of
buoyancy in Hollywood motion picture
stocks are at an all-time high
production is at its peak movies are
doing better than ever so what are we
doing in Santa Monica with six sponsors
and what a glamorous audience we have
here tonight I'm sorry I can't wait and
what a glamorous and what a glamorous
audience we have here tonight mink
ermine diamonds it looks like the Palm
Springs unemployment office and there
they are
ladies and gentlemen there they are the
real Untouchables looks like Walt
Disney's rumpus room
my kids refer to my trophy room as naked
city
I shouldn't complain I got the
Humanitarian Award last year and if I
can stay human for two more years I get
to keep it no it's tough
it's it's tough being a comedian I
called up the Academy to see if I want
anything and they operated laughs for 20
minutes you feel pretty bad when the
nominations come out you're not included
I don't care for myself but it's tough
on my kids now they think their mother
married the wrong leaven Vince exactly
this show is being taped for later
viewing by any Russians who happen to be
out of the world right now they're sure
getting even for Disneyland aren't they
and that pilot Yuri Alekseyevich Gagarin
there's a name that will go down in all
the history books misspelled the
Russians may be the first in space but
we have cigarettes with a hint of mint
actually sorry again actually actually
it doesn't matter whose first and a
President Kennedy can convince us of
that he should be here tonight
it just it just proves one thing they're
German scientists are better than our
German science
anyway ladies and gentlemen they've been
showing some great pictures this year
Exodus about the Republicans
the apartment Sinatra's life story Sons
and Lovers about bings family
Elmer Gantry bun in the organ loft
and never on Sunday about a Greek coffee
break
I miss never on Sunday my teenage son
didn't think I was ready for Butterfield
8 was the story of one girls fight
against American Telepictures
the pictures psycho taught our children
a valuable lesson never take a shower
and then there was Almer gantry don't
smoke in church
Italian movies are doing well here
especially those showing American
gangsters I think it's a shame we're not
all bad and in England they have the
angry young men making angry young
pictures the mystery is how do they get
the money from satisfied old banks
anyway we have some distinguished
nominees Laurence Olivier Glynis John's
Peter Ustinov Melina Mercury Trevor
Howard I think we're carrying foreign
aid too far and Sal Mineo for Exodus I
didn't know he was bar Mitzvahed
we all know how Jack Lemmon got in there
lending his apartment to members of the
Academy but this has been a year for
high-priced pictures high budget
pictures anything under two million
dollars is considered a short subject
we've had tremendous spectacles like
Exodus the Alamo Spartacus with
thousands of extras and it's just the
beginning right now Sam Spiegel has more
men under arms than NATO and we even
have a new service now hurts when a
country
when Jerry Wald heard about the war in
the Congo he said who's producing it the
movies have had a great year some
pictures made money even with the seal
of approval this was quite a year for
the ladies Elizabeth tenor played a lady
of easy virtue in Butterfield 8 Nancy
Kwan played a lady of the evening in
Suzie Wong Malina mercury played a
Grecian urn ER and never on Sunday and
Shirley Jones played a girl of the
streets in Elmer Gantry put them all
together does this spell surelly cookies
to you
and so on with the awards and now for
all you nominees if you'll close your
eyes burt lancaster will lead you in
prayer
I suppose we can begin making the awards
it's passed Carlin Kennedy's bedtime so
it's
it's safe for the losers remarks to be
heard on the air the first awards to be
made tonight will be presented by one of
Hollywood's happiest married couples
Janet Leigh and Tony Curtis right here
don't let that hand-holding bit fool you
one's an imposter and the others are
psycho
well at least they stopped making jokes
about my wearing girls clothes just
because a fella wears girls clothes in
one picture though he's darling your
voice is getting a little shrill excuse
me
let's get back to being Hollywood's
happiest couple you read the first
announcement
it is our pleasant assignment to present
the awards the best documentary films
for 1960 the nominees for Best
Documentary Feature are the horse with a
flying tail Larry Lansford rebel in
paradise Robert de Fraser beyond roses
thank you darling you open this you have
the longest nails
the winner is the horse with the flying
tail
the very special thanks to Walt Disney
and my sincere appreciation to the
United States equestrian team thank you
the nominees for the best documentary
short subjects are beyond silence United
States Information Agency a city called
Copenhagen Danish government film office
George groats interregnum Charles and
Altena Carrie Jessup inna James Hill
universe Colin Lowe the envelope please
the winner Jessup inna James Hill
big THANK YOU from James he'll do
subpoena to the Academy first high honor